so what's up y'all we are going to
celebrate a few people's last nights in
Vegas but we kind of wanted to do a
group gathering or Bart and Joe wanted
to for the JK family because they're so
dope like that and so we're over here
picking up snacks for everybody so they
can get their fat and drunk on ha ha I
just happen to be two of those one of my
favorite shits on earth fruit tart good
that's because Bloods and Cripps get
along on this [ __ ] I've been reprimanded
I'm not a big candy fan but I'm pretty
sure people would like gummy bears I'm
not a god I thought I have much is
what's on the party shopping me
something everything that's not
nutritious basically and it's not for me
it's for everybody else
I'm a sample of college material once
again not even me I love Russia
now we got to get a couple of beers for
everybody I'm not a big beer drinker but
everybody wants to have a little bit of
libations and they want to have a little
fun so let's see what they want to get
to get [ __ ] up and get pregnant I mean
they get [ __ ] up on us you gotta make
sure you are lying so you're gonna upset
some people what's in this shopping cart
no too much too much did everything for
the park a we got your fruits because uh
we want to stay healthy
we got fruits we got the sweets for the
sweet people
we got the chips for the chips and we
got the gushers for more health reasons
made with real fruit so far we got a lot
of different snacks it's not personally
what I like I like to have vegetables
and celery you know obviously be the
most fittest and the only fitness expert
in the group but of course they were all
arguing with me so I had to give in I'm
not somebody who likes to fight with
people so I was like you know what just
[ __ ] it didn't get the gushers I am
proud to pre-wash you know I did grab
for the office but I didn't grab these
Jana Pringles I don't know for the
gushers you just jumped right on it no I
just said who gushers said she was like
food I never said grab them I just
notice that they were gushers they're
like a child you gonna take the child to
okay
so today we are about to go up and have
the collective JK family
I guess sweet party so we're just going
to get together drink a little bit have
some fun and just spend time with the
family so you guys know that we went to
Japan together that was freaking awesome
but then I realized that a lot of the
group wasn't able to come because it was
just too many [ __ ] people but he said
you know what we got to have another
trip just for everybody else that
weren't able to go and not only that we
wanted to bond even more and do this
more often so thank you guys for coming
down and let's hope that we could do
this like every Saturdays grab the mics
interstate so it's awesome all of you
guys right here um we travel far and
wide and don't gamble I Harris the crown
is lovely is pretty good last night so
afterwards if you guys want to go there
go there Caesars was packed last night
so we had the heads-up game but we had
it charades to it but we added a little
a little bit of a twist so instead of
having one person guess with that shirt
we flipped it around where we have a
whole group of people do sure raised for
the one person to guess she was [ __ ]
as a [ __ ] the person that I compete the
most with in charades is definitely geo
she has this tendency to always talk
[ __ ] to me and I'm just saying right now
that I for sure know that I will never
lose at anything against her
oh yeah yeah you losers on this is
sitting in your dream god dammit Oh
Rico yeah uh it's a scene you can smoke
wait there let's just [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] My Mind's a little blank right
now when we got this [ __ ] there's no way
we're going to lose losers have to punch
themselves in the vagina the nest oh
okay what do you do when your legal age
is at total wrong yes but it's what what
that want us to date the day happy
birthday Johnny 110 100 zero you're
gonna find silver oh that's a nice cool
oh my god early hair oh they never had
sex before it's a comedy wardrobe
version yeah oh oh
the best person who probably plays
you're raising our team has to be in
terms of guessing [ __ ] I say it's Bart
just because I know for sure if it's me
and Bart you got like a mental connect
because our brain has like the same
[ __ ] wavelength so watch just watch
fix it when you all in you only live no
yeah let's say that
all right sure a little yeah so team one
wait is this one of us q1 got 29 points
all right all right
jim has 31
yeah
first game obviously we won cuz we're
[ __ ] tight like that Julia said we
only won by two points which I think was
absolute [ __ ] she obviously
miscounted julia can't even get the
[ __ ] thing right which is juice
Bigelow of male gigolo that gonna sit
like pistachio and [ __ ] so counting
abilities aren't that great I love the
girl though yes sound oh honey oh good
buddy
morning okay so we're outta money
my name is good uh I'm hiding a project
creaking oh yeah yeah I think like the
amount of people that we had that we
could make a game like absolutely insane
I'm pretty sure and plus we've kind of
flipped the rules on charades and
everybody has a really strong
personality so it was really intense
Oh walking bowling buddy yeah buddy
court lady hi
I had the most difficult time possible
because [ __ ] Devyn decide to eat a
popsicle like it was a dick how the [ __ ]
is that popsicle and then the word was
splits right these full this full
[ __ ] Devon and Ryan does this is your
Superman who the [ __ ] makes this is
splits oh man yeah
you woke me up after you bagged her head
no what the [ __ ] Mart was doing
throughout that whole game that's the
point where Bart was like pretending to
be on rollerblades mission all right no
what about here
the first one was only 32 get 9.1 get
second games they won I'll give it to
that but what I didn't like was when
they won they shoved in our face no
class handled our win with class unlike
these ingrates
we did not shove it in their face they
have no class yeah it's kind of great to
come out here and just hang out with
your really good friends and also people
that you work with I think a lot of the
times like you guys don't get to see the
hard work that we do to kind of put out
like regular content on a regular basis
you know in order for us to show
appreciation to you know for what we do
to and also to like every bus that we
work with we have to relax a little bit
and sometimes we forget to do that so
when we come out here we get to bond and
forget about work for just a second even
though when work is fun sometimes you
need a reset and it only like fortifies
the bond that we have with each other
because if we don't work as a union as a
family that nothing really gets done and
everybody is a very important part to
this machine that makes everything run
really smoothly